hello everyone it's peter brown with a
gamespot news update last week amazon
announced prime day where we'll
celebrate its 20th anniversary on July
fifteenth with a sale it's calling
bigger than Black Friday now walmart has
retaliated with a sale of its own what's
the catch to participate in amazon prime
day well you have to be a member of
amazon prime in order to take advantage
of it and walmart is trying to
capitalize on this point we've heard
some retailers are charging a hundred
dollars to get access to a sale reese's
statement from walmart com CEO Fernando
Madera but the idea of asking customers
to pay extra in order to save money just
doesn't add up for us Walmart will roll
out special deals with no hidden costs
or admission fees this coming week
through its website and unlike amazon
prime day which will be held for one day
only on the 15 walmart sale period will
run for multiple days in addition
shoppers will qualify for free shipping
on purchases over thirty-five dollars
instead of the usual fifty dollar
minimum there's been no word yet on what
will be on sale but I'd be willing to
bet we'll see some video games at
discounted prices so you're dedicated
amazon customer is going to stick with
your prime membership or are you going
to go to Walmart and save some money
without having to sign up for a new
account or just take advantage of bolt
let us know in the comments below and
get ready for some crazy savings next
week and as always stay tuned to
gamespot com for all your gaming news